I think the guy on the phone in the
liquor store thought I was messing with
I could spell if you under 18 hang up
now it's a surprise Church [ __ ]
you're sitting there thinking what
you're gonna do with look who popped up
your uncle Joey you [ __ ] like I
said if you're under 18 hang up now
I don't want your mother calling me
tomorrow
there you go it's gonna be that type of
night we say beat that [ __ ] that's a
looming limbus cloud right there listen
surprise Church we're ready to go get
the [ __ ] terminals whatever you're
doing I don't steal your mother's cancer
pills take chemo pills it's that type of
[ __ ] night you understand me we got a
special guest in the house we're going
deep deep deep into the murky waters no
it's not heroin no it's not to minnows
no it's not [ __ ] Cosby pills there
you go [ __ ] nice little tequila
water and [ __ ] number one are you
[ __ ] nuts or what run to the liquor
store we're going deep tonight I'm gonna
see Mexicans and Clint Eastwood and
[ __ ] la Bamba Ritchie [ __ ] some
nylons what's his name Ritchie Valens is
making a comeback
number one tequila get your [ __ ]
together [ __ ] we switched it up
on your seat that's why Damien mine and
went on [ __ ] Saturday because he
wanted a goin for leg locks from time to
time it's not about the edibles it's not
about the answer it's not about the
heroin you gotta take a little shot
tequila like a [ __ ] savage you
understand me and I know you're on
medication you got chlamydia I don't
give a [ __ ]
tonight's your lucky night mister run
whites in the house so do what you need
to do go run get you got five minutes
they're gonna get me for whatever the
[ __ ] that I borrowed tequila rum I don't
give a [ __ ] if you steal your grandma's
little ass
two shots of vodka she got left until
the check comes in I don't give a [ __ ]
take it take it
here we go Lee's ready for a bonding you
ready do you want the shift from the one
I do all this other [ __ ] here we go
just when you thought it was safe oh
this is the safe one the one I drew and
come until next week look at Lee with a
new [ __ ] shirt he went to double XL
up in Topanga Canyon and got himself
into little wardrobe e oh [ __ ] stay
right there I'm gonna win this is the
bomb that killed Carrie Fisher This Is
It this is it
goli all the way like a savage BAM there
you go the Olympics 2028 oh [ __ ] I won't
be in LA are you kidding me or what this
is what I'm talking about
listen I love you watching The
Bachelorette or whatever the [ __ ] you're
watching youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz
there's the man himself are you [ __ ]
kidding me you're like that's 20 a lot
20 of life no-parole you follow me five
minutes youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz
that's the place to be get I'm telling
you don't [ __ ] with me I'm the mood I'm
in tonight I'll go to your house I'll
[ __ ] stab you how I'm feeling
understand me ten minutes youtube.com /
c / Joey Diaz this periscope sponsored
number one [ __ ] tequila the best went
to contest and beat everybody Mexicans
went home crying
Mexicans went home crying when they
tasted this number one tequila and
you're sitting there drinking that
[ __ ] rubbish natete not your stomach
this is the real [ __ ] how many is this
is what I'm [ __ ] talking about
nobody's got a nine-year-old plant and
this is how we're doing it here with
number one tequila get your [ __ ]
together run to the liquor store
youtube.com slash C / Joey Diaz you
gotta change it up from time to time and
keep these [ __ ] guessing stay
black